hello good afternoon to all our
Latin American brothers and welcome
to the presentation roles in the design and
construction of your bar bioterio or
animal facility
louis orilla and who is speaking to you we have
prepared this presentation with the
aim of disseminating the practices of
the design process of the bioterio and
we hope that you can apply them
in your next projects
louis will not be with us today
but i can tell you that louis works
as an assistant director the director
of the university of texas at san
antonio has more or less 15 years of
experience in the
brand and laboratory animal field and at the same time
louis is the director and professor of a
course architecture engineering and
planning of laboratory animal facilities
for the
online master's program that is taught in the
college of medicine at the university of
transition
and well me paulina buggies some
know you for my collaboration
in hotels.com I'm an architect  from the
university of chile and has indicated the
last 16 years of my career to the design
and planning of laboratories,
especially to vivariums and what I
like to say is that I saw other viviaries they
were my first love
please take note of our
email addresses luisillo
We will be happy to talk to you
after this or answer any questions
you have
so let's begin the emphasis of our
presentation not the design but the
process to which the institutions are
subjected during the process during the
design with a vivarium or an animal facility
that is why the objective is  understand the phases
of the development of a project design
implementation and also understand the role
that each of us has in this
process
so as an introduction we are
going to start with a statement is
a rule is one of my
favorite statements is a declaration of
interests  interests that should always
be at the base of any institution
that uses before  imals in research is a
statement to which we must return
as designers whenever we are
faced with a conflict in the
design process we must always ask ourselves
if what we are doing if the
solution we are giving is supporting
the result of the research button
and why  Therefore, the health of the animals,
this statement is what differentiates the
commission of a vivarium from any other
commission. Now in Chile we call it a
commission, but what I mean by the
charge is from any other architectural project,
from any other work,
let's call it  you do it here from
any other request ok
then the day comes when your
design project and construction of an
animal facility becomes a reality the
perception is that these two
true components exist in the entity of the
institution
the entity and the architect that come together
that puts these puzzle pieces together
but the truth is that they are not high
components it is a set of equipment
specialized and each team has its
own group,
let's also remember that what
differentiates this team is our user and
our client, which in this case are the
animals, so what we do
first of all is
carefully study the environment where our
main client operates
like this  that we are going to look at the
environment where rodents develop, it
is essential, not only important, it is
essential for the design team to
understand that the environment
in which, in this case, rodents
is made up of many environments and that
each one of them  they depend on many
variables to the extent that we can
control and balance those variables
we are supporting the health and well-being of
the animals which results in
reliable data which in the end is good
science the physical environment let's
see if this works for me the physical environment
there is less high
is only a part of this very
complex system of interaction because for
example  the impact that
the level of light and even vibrations
transmitted by the proximity of equipment
or when desired any other
generator of vibrations can have can affect
the behavior and reproduction
of rodents and therefore truly affect
the physiological levels of animals
and they alter the
data and altered data is not reliable right
ok in the same way the building also
houses those who are in charge of the
trial of the daily
animal court so we now conceive the animal room
as a building that houses
functional spaces that support
a program of  research in balance
where we consider human well-being
in relation to animal well-being now
the factors that we can control of what
we call the human factor are the
economy and the workload the
organization of work as well because
we remember that buildings this type
of buildings have  a life of 24 hours
a day seven days a week 365  days
a year and that we always have staff
working and caring for the animals
so we add the human factor
to this statement now because we made
this introduction because perhaps one of
the most important aspects of the role that
we all have when we are involved
in a building of this  The guy is to understand
this request, then educate, learn from
each other, connect the important points
and agree on what the goal
of the team is and, even more important,
agree on what is the ulterior motive of what
we do and that is that the results
of the  research to benefit
human life and the life of animals
ok so we start the
design process with that view that
the design decisions and the selection
of systems are going to support and give
priority to animal
welfare and human welfare and  they are going to tire me so much
that I repeat that now the most
typical steps although I am sure that they vary
from country to country are these 8 that are  Still
here in front of you more or
less now it should be noted that the
participation of an institution and its
users is critical in the first three
or four phases and that is where we are going to
pay more attention in this presentation,
the rest we are just going to  define
let's start with
the programming and planning
stage at this stage we talk a lot about the
goals and vision of the institution and
what are the components of the
research program for example in the position
the true request to design a vivarium
for the national institute of health  of a
country is very different from the commission of a
biomedical studies entity the
species vary the densities vary and
type of research sometimes also
some institutions have an
infectious disease program and others do not
this does not help to inform
the type of spaces that are  animal facility is
going to have so we can suggest
growth scenarios and establish
a strategy which is the
per  or in a few words programming is
the first point you will see and it is to translate
this use of space and operations to a
quantification of area so we know
in square meters in square feet that
what we need
now those who participate
participate in the institution true and
architects and engineers now
the institution is the one that brings the
teams that are going to be fundamental for
the development of the program because they are not
only the leaders of that institution that
participate in this stage but they are all
those who touch
in one way or another in the activity of
a vivarium for  For example, it
is critical for the maintenance personnel
with the engineers of a certain building
if it is a renovation that they are
present, they are the individuals who
know or the group that knows the most
deeply
the function before the operation of that
building if it is going to  be a
renovation
at this stage the sooner they
can get involved in this process the better and
in fact each of  e
team members assume their position and the decision
to be a good active member and he stressed
that being an active member and
contributor to decisions at this
stage is also critical now on the
side of architects and engineers it
is also key that there is a
knowledge of the guide for the care
and use of laboratory animals
as well as other standards that the market is
true in the national institute of
house here in the usa
there are also two more standards than in the one
that is used which is the european and and  also the
guide for use caring for animals in
agriculture
now what we are together
what they are together are
work sessions where we study together with the
needs of the physical space of the
systems and equipment now why we do
this because in the end what we want to
do  together is to have a
design criteria now it is a design criteria
that adjusts to the needs of each
client it is not a design criteria this
this is not a  recipe what we are
presenting here is not a recipe it is a
design criteria it will be adapted to
the specific program of each institution
here we also analyze the terrain
we start from the terrain the
safety and accessibility conditions
true we make the first evaluation
at costs one level  well macro
because in the end we want to
reach this design criteria again and establish
list sizes of spaces and the
performance of the mechanical,
electrical and plumbing or plumbing systems
that will serve those spaces
now how we do it
we like to distribute it more or less  between
groups 33 large sessions one is
learning from what you have and what
this means learning to understand which
is which is first of all their
research program learning how
they use it how it works how they operate
what is good what is bad
and what  is the goal and vision of the
institution
now if that does not exist then
we start with number 2 where
we analyze  We and what we analyze is
what we call here the
pierre institutions, which are the
institutions that are similar to
yours, so with that we compare among ourselves, we
talk with the people who are all
the leaders at all levels, we understand the
deficiencies and we document
why the third step when  we propose
solutions when when we want to
identify a way to develop
this plan we need
a concept of needs that are already
ours we acquire these are
these solutions and we establish
priorities based on what we have
learned
so this is not very complicated
ask me more now here important
and  The most important thing is to give
those who work in the animal facility the opportunity to
have a voice in these meetings. He
emphasized here the importance that the
representatives of the animal program, whether they
are managers, supervisors, or
directors, be present and be
active members of this process and that
they bring their own team of
staff  also at all levels
share decisions include
technical staff of course give
priority to meetings that are face to
face and also seek advice from
those who have already had the
experience
now that it is very important underlined the
guide
for architect engineer the chapter
dedicated to  the fundamental physical plant
read it understand it and use it now for
the representatives of the animal program
you are already the experts in this in
this book
your fundamental role is that it is
standard the design and care simply
open
it is also critical to understand what
elements we can control of the program
and  Here I am going to share an example
to simplify all this word to
underline the idea that during this
process we discover and understand that
many times we have to give up
spaces, sacrifice some spaces for
storage, for example, and now you
know why this photo was taken.  the
day that are the photos that we take them
Quitectos we love to show
in marketing the main corridor from a
previous video the day the client entered
and these that come now
are the photos of how it was really
used
and this is not necessarily negative
this is the way in which this corridor
It had to work because the priority
of space during the
programming and planning stage was given to
the housing rooms and we knew that
if we gave a wider corridor that
corridor during the time of
change of cages would serve to
store for as a  restyling that he
but here
the everything everything necessary to make the
changes in the pieces
the important thing what I want to emphasize
here is that it
is necessary to know in advance that this
base in the operation is important that
those who are involved in the
operation understand that it is going  to having to
define a
is a professional standard but follow a
standard operating procedure
for this to work properly
and that's all we are liking it is in
a negative form now what is the
end result of this this
scheduling and planning task the
result is documentation of a
process of this needs
assessment that reflects the contribution of all
team members and they are
based on experience now
this this document for example here
this what this example I put here to
see if this works for me again
ok this work is the study of a
capacity of boxes
because this this specific client
we did a study for rodents
a study  for aquatics
and another for other medium-sized animals, in
this case they were pigeons and also rabbits,
all of this, all the justification, what I am
saying about this programming
document is a document that reflects how and
why
the sizes of the enclosures
and the quality of the  campuses reflect
the specific program of each
institution and we have to support them
with the calculation of all this data and
then to  In addition, if we go
to another area, this is an example of a
calculation of
the washing area for
equipment performance, what happens when
we only have rodents, what happens
when we have one for rodents and another for
rabbits?
This document must also comply with
or  exceed the requirements of the guide
if we have used the guide as the basis it is
the standard then it will meet or
access them and what it also does is that it
establishes a design criteria and now
we are going to define what a design criteria is
and although it is
I am going to read it written there, it is a written document that
establishes the general and
specific parameters that designers and
engineers together with the builder must
comply with. In
the end, it ends up being like a
book with five chapters and let's see, for
example, I am going to give you some examples.  the
chapter the chapter of the
direct criteria nico is going to establish
first of all the site the analysis
of the site where this building is going to be
built
all  s the associations the access the
nearby things how the week is managed
manage the privacy
then the sizes of the spaces so
that animals with want city for
space when these are the heavens
what kind of corridor or
corridor system are they going to have materials and
for  vibration noise mitigation and
each that for each type of part of
course
and can heating ventilation and air
conditioning
which are with the criteria of
pressurization of controls
perhaps energy conservation
temperature humidity electricity the
same lighting by room
the emergency system systems of
access security also later
plumbing or plumbing
where are the sinks here
priority will be given to the distribution of
water to the teams where we will have
tempered water
what will be the criteria for
distributing gases if necessary
where will they be  those gases
commission now if you look at the
first one of the first of these  light cough
-commission was almost at the end
but what we do
in the programming and planning is
that the commission chapter establishes the
performance of the systems including
criteria the memory of all these
criteria including a criterion of
temperature balance pressurization
now all this study la
la  I would say the length of how long it takes us
to do this study depends on
the magnitude and the complexity
of the program, but
once this phrase for the design
of the vivarium is documented and everyone has done it and they
have had an opinion and we will say
but they
have analyzed all the tones  that are
generating this discussion we go to
the next step, which is the climatic design
now with this previous document
approved
the client has a document and we
keep the other document so what
we do is that we use the elements
of that document design criteria to
start  to manipulate spaces to
scale and proportion then this at the
end  it is like a transition between the
program
and
and a design
here also specifically we start to
study and share with the client
the ratio for example of
accommodation rooms versus procedure room
now what do we do
first
of course we divide we develop
basic concepts of the relationship between
the basic components  of one
of your program but also
the basic division between the components
of a vivarium, which are the
animal area and the support area, and how
these are subdivided
later, they study, we study different
organizational concepts,
this is the moment where the architect and the
team  specialist should discuss
advantages and disadvantages of certain
distribution schemes,
for example, in this case,
the single corridor
versus a double corridor, right,
am
also
how the
whole issue of receiving animals and inputs will be handled
with respect to the site and how it will be managed.
handle
the input area and control from
there  well
this is again this is a
specific to a specific
new program a recipe
ok what I want most important of
this the important thing is to question the
solutions and ask for clarification
of everything you do not understand
and for this lesson I was to keep
a  open line of communication at all
levels to
discuss and analyze the scenarios of
the concepts presented is critical I
know I have said this word many
times it is critical but that is the case with
all disciplines because at the same time
that we are sharing with
you thematic designs engineers
they are
giving climatic solutions also to
those same problems
now what is the result
if another document this document
includes the justification of the
architectural concept and the systems concept
that best fits and responds to the
objective of the client's program
includes all designs schematic
here  that were developed at the beginning and
of course also
Once this document is reviewed
and accepted, we move on to the next stage,
which is the development of the design.
It should be noted here that still in these
three, step number three, here
we still have the same team, nobody, none of
the team members have ceased to
exist.  in no meeting
we are still all together now what does it
mean to develop the design during
this stage what we did is we took
all the elements from the
previous document from all the previous documents
the spaces start to become
spaces scale and proportion
what we do is like already  We have
worked together with the engineers,
for example, in this case
there is already a structure for the
building, there is a structural module,
so we study the space in
detail and how these spaces fit
into a structural grid. In this case,
this is a study of one of a
washing room analysis showed that the most efficient
structurally and for this for the
ta  The best of this this program was this
solution that shows you the disk in a
tunnel and a shelf elevator
now once we have that area,
right, we already did the area of ​​the washing area,
we began
to understand how those areas interact
Now the most important thing in this stage is
that the team of engineering architects
present this in a format
so that the client is able to
present questions and express the
need to understand beyond what
we will be showing them,
for example, to
separate circulation areas.  and of use
here in this case there were we had two
animal housing areas
so later with two you although
looking for me there with each one had
a specific access
now again this is something that works
for this specific client but the most
important thing here
is to
ask is to review and understand why
a solution of this type because the
solutions that are being presented are
adequate but the pro  Your program
this that in the basics and of course
coordinate with the specialties because the
more we develop the
architectural design the engineers are
developing the design of the systems
and we return to compare with the
design criteria is what we are the size of
the pieces the  size of the
laundry room of the storage room of
the office still has to be
we have to keep that in check that
all the design criteria are adequate
to the criteria that we are sharing with
the users
important at this stage also to
check the  Costs
are very important because this will
give us a more or less
macro basis of how we are doing with
Bayern, right
here some of the teams are also
beginning to carry out risk studies,
not just risk studies, what happens if we don't have
electricity?  for three days but
also disaster risk that is
specifically added in the latest
edition of the guide
but more  that nothing understands the
design decisions to support or refute
them also
now what the result of this
design development
at the end of this stage will have a
defined architecture plan with the
engineering systems that have been
evaluated and chosen to meet the
established demands  for you now
also in this type in this at this
stage we add a
sheet what we call definition sheets
which are specific descriptions of
each piece
for example in the design criteria
we said all the housing pieces
is an example all the housing pieces are
going to  be
negative view regarding the corridor
this as where we can specify what
type of differential pressure at this
stage these definition sheets to
our piece think maybe there is a
group of housing floor pieces
that are going to have different characteristics
because that will  to host
at any point in a
different program also
with that development  After the approved design,
we start with the construction documents.
At this stage, the work is
over. We
no longer work together as much as the
architects-engineers, who are so responsible
for designing and developing the
technical specifications
of the equipment, the finishing materials,
working with the design criteria.  to
present the user with this package
we also check the costs again
the important thing about this and at this stage and
although you two are still
present is to minimize and avoid the
drastic changes
since making drastic changes in the
design we increase the risk of
coordination and more  that the execution time is nothing
because when
more or less in the development and
design stage we already have an
anticipated execution time and that anticipated execution time
is linked to a cost
then minimizing and avoiding
drastic changes in being at this stage is
important  to keep costs in
check as well and
keep re  alizing reviewing and being there
being present
now comes the time
for award cost proposals
the project is in the hands of the construction team
the documents have been approved and are
official
and once awarded
construction begins now at this
stage
although at most  the
institution's team is better the institution's work team
is smaller It is important
that this team follows the process
and that team also has to be a
team that is
familiar with the
development stages and with all the standards
that were established from the outset  first
step of programming and that the whole
team attends each
construction meeting changing
now to commission the stage of commissioning
and validation we are going to define it although
to do them forget what is
the difference
because the systems that we specify not
only must work but they must
work  under specific parameters,
for example,
the commission process confirms that a
autoclave reaches the
specified temperature true and that steam is
present it is connected to one at a
specific pressure to meet to complete
a cycle
afterwards but the validation process
what makes the validation valid is that it
tests that autoclave and confirms
that the items  exposed to a cycle they
were effectively sterilized
so what validation does is
confirm that the processes and
operating protocols are met and
this commissioning commission and validation
are all aspects that must be used
across the work we conduct
and
in the mechanical, electrical
and  plumbing
now final recommendations
more than anything
shape your team assign tasks
but what I said so many times
throughout this presentation the presence of the
users and not just the leaders is
vital in all meetings and as
we say here let's always sit down together
the table to discuss important issues
and let's all be perspectives
because  we must not forget
why we do all this true because
to maintain the goals of our
research program and support those
results we must give priority to the
health of the animals and also
those who publish them
because all of us who are here
share this true dream of
improve human health animal health
through research and live in
a better world as architects true
as researchers as presidents of
an institution we only have to
work together
and with that I say goodbye let me see if there are
any questions
today I am not going to ask
ah
I can answer questions in it
as his brother so thank you very much
on behalf of the company so that
I represent bs and the structure on
behalf of Luis and the University of
Texas San Antonio and Luis who is there
greeting you I thank you very much for having
participated as
well  an affectionate fraternal hug to
all my friends from Chile to faith take
them out a long time ago  so everything
and do
not hesitate to contact us by email again do not hesitate to contact us with any
questions.